[Music]
[Applause]
the Dancing with the Stars season 27
finale turned out to be get this the
bachelor nation gift that keeps on
giving not only did we get to see this
hilarious performance supporting Joe's
great and you know I mean I do sit-ups
for a reason but we also got our first
look at Colton Underwood's upcoming
season of The Bachelor hopefully by the
end of this I'm down on one man to
celebrate the fall finale of Dancing
with the Stars grocery-store Joe and his
pro partner Jenna Johnson pulled off an
epic surprise featuring some very
special backup dancers
[Applause]
got one too
right after the performance ABC aired
the first footage of Colton Underwood's
upcoming season of The Bachelor sure
enough it addressed the topic everyone's
talking about I am a virgin that's just
a small part of who I am you could lose
your virginity this week sexual intimacy
is a big part of any relationship lots
of Tears
drama and even this happened
I'm holy
[Music]
golde turn my god
et was backstage with former bachelor
and Dancing with the Stars contestant
Nick vile we did be a nice sneak peek of
Colton's season tonight have you spoken
to Colton at all we know that I have not
are they done filming you know more than
I do have you heard any rumblings about
how a season went
I really have I mean I really I didn't
even know they were done wrapping
I don't ask these questions you know
there's a there's a poster that came out
a couple of days ago that alluded to his
virginity it said he has a lot to lose
do you feel like they're going too far
with the whole virginity of it all I
personally am NOT interested in whether
Colton loses his virginity or not I am
interested in whether he meets someone
he has feelings for I mean I just
whatever like if he alright why are you
gonna find someone that you have
feelings for such a great question you
can you as a buffer
witness is such a great question you
know I haven't I've been working really
hard on other things and I started
essentially a line sometimes that
there's that but no no lucky lady well
hopefully she'll feel lucky I don't know
you make of Kaitlyn and Shawn breaking
out I don't you know they had a good
long run
I truly haven't kept in touch mom so I
really don't know anything about
anything
I like anyone who goes through a breakup
I'm sure it's hard and I wish anyone who
goes through a cup all the best as I
would then my last question for you it's
a hard one
there's rumors that Vanessa and Peter
have been hanging out talking I mean I
don't again I heard it here heard it
from you first
I'm just delivering Nick vile all the
news today really busy you know I if
that's true good congratulations that's
fantastic I mean I would love her to be
happy and if that makes her happy then
I'm all for it what are you doing for
Thanksgiving whatever plan I leave
tomorrow to go home visit the family for
a few days the loved ones and eat some
turkey watching football
[Music]
[Applause]
you